BRET.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN, THANK YOU.
MANY DEMOCRATS WHO HOPED TO
CHALLENGE THE PRESIDENT AND NEXT
YEAR'S ELECTION ARE JOINING THE
COURSE OF CRITICISM OVER LAST
NIGHT'S CHANCE.
PETER DOOCY SHOWS US THAT
TONIGHT.
>> CANDIDATE SEEM TO BE
CONCERNED THAT AFTER AN
ILHAN OMAR-INSPIRED CHANT OF THE
2020 ELECTION IS NO LONGER JUST
ABOUT RIGHT OR LEFT, IT'S ABOUT
LIFE OR DEATH.
>> IF I WERE HER, I WOULD
IMMEDIATELY CALL THE FBI AND SAY
WHAT DO I NEED FOR PROTECTION.
>> KAMALA HARRIS AND
ELIZABETH WARREN BOTH DESCRIBE
THE PRESIDENT'S REELECTION RALLY
AS RACIST AND XENOPHOBIC.
JOE BIDEN TRIED TO ADD
HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
>> WHEN THE CROWD STARTED
YELLING "SEND THEM BACK," WHEN
HAS THAT EVER HAPPENED OTHER
THAN THE LAST TIME REMEMBER
EVERYTHING ABOUT GEORGE WALLACE?
>> STRATEGISTS ARGUES SQUARING
OFF AGAINST SOME OF THE MOST
POLITICALLY PROGRESSIVE MEMBERS
OF THE HOUSE CAN CARRY SOME
AWARDS.
BECAUSE HE MANAGED TO MAKE THEM
THE FACE OF THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THAT'S GENIUS, THAT'S GREAT.
IT'S WONDERFUL POLITICS.
WISH THERE WAS A BETTER WAY HE
COULD HAVE DONE IT.
>> STILL, NEARLY TWO DOZEN
DEMOCRATS ARE FOCUSED ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP NARROWED HIS
FOCUS.
JOE BIDEN.
>> HE'S NOT PREPARED, HE'S NOT
MENTALLY PREPARE, THAT'S HIS
PROBLEM.
>> TWO, BERNIE SANDERS.
>> IS ACTUALLY NOT EVEN A
DEMOCRAT.
ISN'T HE INDEPENDENT?
HE MISSED HIS TIME.
>> THREE, KAMALA HARRIS.
>> THEY HAVE A NEW ONE THE HELL
OUT OF BIDEN AT THE DEBATE.
>> FOUR, ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> I WAS DRIVING HER CRAZY SO
SHE WENT OUT AND HIRED A GUY TO
CHECK THE BLOOD.
>> AND FIVE, PETE BUTTIGIEG.
FICO IF THAT'S THE HOT YOUNG
STAR, I GUESS I JUST DON'T KNOW
START THEM ANYMORE.
THAT IS NOT A STAR.
>> FOR THE BIG STARS ON THE LEFT
IS WE GOT A FRESHMAN DEMOCRATS
AND THE SO-CALLED "SQUAD" WHO
COULD BE DOING PRESIDENT TRUMP A
FAVOR.
>> EVERY TIME THEY SPEAK OR
TWEET, HE SHOULD THANK THEM.
THE REALITY IS THEY ARE GETTING
FURTHER AND FURTHER OUT OF THE
MAINSTREAM.
>> IN 2016, CANDIDATE TRUMP
FOUND HIMSELF IN THE MIDDLE OF
FIGHTS WITH LAWMAKERS,
ENTERTAINERS, EVEN THE POPE, AND
HE STILL IN MY COLLECTION.
SO NOW RIVALS AND SUPPORTERS
MIGHT HAVE TO CONSIDER THIS